the greatest threat to America right now
is it World War 3 is it the completely
open border oh what was that and what
else no it's not that it's not even the
sun monster no you're blind no no it's
white people stand up against the poison
of white supremacists I did my inaugural
address through a single out as the most
dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white supremacy
thank you
[Music]
and I'm not saying this because I'm at a
black hpcu I say Wherever I Go the most
dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white supremacy and I'm not
just saying this because I'm obviously
pandering to you to historically black
college no no
I say it wherever I go